COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH --
TWENTY CANCER BY COLD ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVISED ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS BEING MADE.
IT'S ALSO BEING TELEVISED --
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
THEIR CAREER [inaudible]
CERVANTES HERE [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER HERE GRAYSON OKAY.
MAYES.
MS AREA PRESENT SALAS
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A CORPSMAN WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA.
IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA SOME OF THAT COVERS CAL.
HAVE BECOME EXECUTIVE I MISS
ABOUT THESE --
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HIGH WHO WE I
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE KOREA AYE CARILLO
HIGH CERVANTES AYE.
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
AYE GALLAGHER AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE MAYES THIS AREA.
I IS THERE AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
MAYES.
YEAR AND AYE AYE MAYES AYE AYE.
REGULATIONS HOUSES OF THE MOST
HAS PASSED IN THE SCHOOLS GLAZER